For this video, I’m going to show you how
to make colorful and cool looking easter eggs,
using a few packs of drink crystals you might
already have in the pantry.
All you need for this project are a few packs
of Kool-Aid and some hard boiled eggs.
Start by filling 12 containers with 1/2 cup
of water. And if you don’t have 12 glasses
handy, you could try using a large muffin
tray instead. Now go ahead and open a pack
of Kool-Aid and pour the whole thing in, making
sure all the drink crystals get dissolved.
When your eggs are cooked and ready for coloring,
look closely and make sure they aren’t cracked,
then carefully lower them into the colored
liquid one at a time.
The moment your egg is completely submerged,
set a timer for 2 minutes exactly, because
they won’t need to soak any longer than
that.
When the time is up, carefully pull the eggs
out of the cups, and use something like a
paper towel to catch any drips, then simply
leave them out to dry for about 5 minutes.
If you used the same flavors I did here, you’ll
end up with a whole rainbow of different colored
easter eggs. And instead of stinking like
vinegar, your house will actually smell fruity
and irresistibly delicious.
You can see the drink crystals give an awesome
assortment of color to your eggs as long as
they’re not left in the dyes for too long,
or knocked round too much when they’re wet.
Now if you don’t already have juice crystals
in your pantry, the good news is you can usually
find them, 5 for a buck, at any local grocery
store. And if you want to keep your project
to $1 or less, try using just these 5 flavors.
In my experience they’ll give you the brightest
colors and give the best variety for your
money.
Alright, let’s take our egg dying to the
next level by decorating them with stickers
and stars. Soak them for 2 minutes like you
did before, but this time you’ll end up
with a whole new species of easter egg, that
are as fun and unique as your imagination.
And if you decide to peel the stickers off,
you’ll see a white pattern where the stickers
used to be, making them fun and cool in a
whole different way.
Now if you want to add some decoration but
don’t have any stickers handy, it’s no
problem. Try drawing on the egg with a white
crayon, or a clear birthday candle instead.
When you pull the egg up out of the dye, your
artwork will magically appear, without any
extra effort.
Well now you know how to use flavored drink
crystals, to color easter eggs any color of
the rainbow.
By the way, the juice crystals are non-toxic
and safe to eat, so when you’re done playing
with the eggs, go ahead and have them for
a snack.
Well that’s it for now. If you like this
video, perhaps you’ll like some of my others.
Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com